die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen Abend wünsche ich
Ihnen viel Fußball gibt es von Rudi
hallo schönen guten Abend unter anderem
auf diese Themen blicken wir heute
Nachwuchssorgen bei der Bundeswehr immer
weniger junge Menschen gehen zur Truppe
der Verteidigungsminister will mehr
Tempo in den bewerbungsprozessen
neue Anklage gegen Trump der
exos-präsident muss erneut vor Gericht
wegen versuchter Wahlbeeinflussung und
seiner Rolle beim Sturm auf das Kapitol
und die Erde Belastungsgrenze seit heute
sind rechnerisch alle nachwachsenden
Ressourcen für das Jahr 2023
aufgebraucht
[Musik]
die Bundeswehr sucht dringend Personal
gerade auch weil sie verstärkt
eingesetzt werden soll aber die
Bundeswehr hat immer größere
Schwierigkeiten Menschen zu finden die
zum Militär wollen sondern die Zahl der
Bewerbungen weiter ab
seht ihr die Bundeswehr 1990 noch knapp
460.000 Soldaten sank die Zahl danach
rapide auch durch Aussetzung der
Wehrpflicht und Personalabbau momentan
sind es noch circa 181.000 aktive in
Uniformen
erklärte Ziel ist es bis 2031 wieder auf
203.000 Soldatinnen und Soldaten zu
kommen Jan Fredrik Fischer berichtet
stramm stehen für die nächste Übung fünf
Tage dürfen hier im
baden-württembergischen Niederstetten
junge Frauen und Männer den
bundeswehralltag erleben die Truppe
zeigt sich dafür von ihrer besten Seite
sie will dringend benötigten Nachwuchs
gewinnen der 18-Jährigen Alexa gefällts
für mich persönlich kommt gerade eher
dieser ähm freiwillige Wehrdienst in
Betracht für 12 Monate einfach mal
reingucken das ist nur ein Jahr und wenn
ich danach sagst nichts für mich dann
kann ich ja immer noch gehen und was
anderes machen damit die ausgerufene
zeitenwände wirklich gelingen kann
braucht es Menschen die sich direkt
längerfristig verpflichten lassen das
weiß auch Boris Pistorius und legt heute
demonstrativ eine Stippvisite im
Stuttgarter karrierecenter ein die
Probleme die Bewerber abschrecken sind
alte Bekannte etwa marode Ausstattung
oder wechselnde dienstorte hinzu kommen
falsche Erwartungen die durch
Werbekampagnen entstehen keine guten
Voraussetzungen im Bohlen mit der freien
Wirtschaft um immer weniger
Schulabgänger wenn wir junge Frauen und
junge Männer für die Bundeswehr
begeistern wollen dann müssen wir Ihnen
auch sagen wie wir Familie und Dienst
unter einen Hut bringen das bedeutet
Flexibilität aber gleichzeitig natürlich
auch die Verlässlichkeit die Zeit drängt
zuletzt gegen die Bewerbung zurück
zwischen Januar und Mai waren es im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr rund 7% weniger
zeitenwände trifft
attraktivitätsprobleme also das junge
Männer und Frauen damit rechnen mussten
über Monate irgendwo in
Auslandseinsätzen zu sein getrennt von
der Familie und inzwischen ist ja die
Lage auch so dass ich viele überlegen
ist das dann vielleicht eine
Kriegssituation für die ich mich jetzt
verpflichte es braucht mehr
Überzeugungsarbeit denn am Ende geht es
auch um die Frage wie werfe ich ist
Deutschland
in Berlin die Zahl der Soldaten und
Soldatinnen soll also steigen aber immer
weniger Menschen bewerben sich bei der
Bundeswehr wie will die Bundesregierung
das lösen
also in den werbeschlagworten klingt das
zumindest lösbar die Anziehungskraft der
Bundeswehr soll gesteigert werden das
Bewerbungsverfahren soll beschleunigt
und vor allem sollen gezielt Frauen und
Mitbürger mit Migrationshintergrund für
die Truppe begeistert werden dahinter
aber ist hier allen politischen
Entscheidungen klar dass das
Nachwuchsproblem der Bundeswehr
mindestens so schwerwiegend ist wie der
Mangel an Ausrüstung und Waffen und das
in einer Zeit in der Sicherheit ja aus
eigener militärischer Kraft zu extrem
wichtig ist selbst der seit Jahren
geplante geringfügige Personalaufbau wir
haben sie eben gesehen scheint kaum noch
zu leisten zu sein denn die
Bewerberzahlen gehen zurück der
demografische Wandel wird das Problem
weiter verstärken und die wenigen
Schulen und Studienabgänger werden ja
auch von der Wirtschaft heftig umworben
für die Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht
fehlen zurzeit jedenfalls Ausbilder und
Kasernen Fazit historius hat auf
absehbare Zeit eine Truppe in Not auch
in Personalnot danke für diese
Einschätzung
eine Woche nach dem Putsch in Niger hat
die westafrikanische Staatengemeinschaft
ECOWAS eine Delegation in das Land
geschickt und mit den neuen
Militärmachthabern zu verhandeln die
ECOWAS hat den Putschisten damit gedroht
militärisch einzugreifen falls der
demokratisch gewählte Präsident war Zoom
von Sonntag an nicht wieder im Amt ist
unterdessen wurden bereits hunderte
Menschen aus Europa aus Niger
ausgeflogen Jan fritzsche
auch heute morgen noch stehen viele
Franzosen am Flughafen in Nigers
Hauptstadt niami an warten darauf in
Sicherheit gebracht zu werden schon in
der Nacht waren die ersten französischen
und italienischen evakuierungsflüge an
den Flughäfen Paris und Rom angekommen
bei den Rückkehrern Erleichterung
wir wissen nicht ob es gefährlich hätte
werden können aber es ist gut zurück zu
sein wir müssen sehen wie sich die Dinge
in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen
entwickeln nach französischen Angaben
sind bislang mehr als 500 Menschen mit
den evakuierungsflügen in Sicherheit
gebracht worden auch deutsche wie
bundesaußenministerin bärbock mitteilte
wir konnten gestern und heute mit Hilfe
unserer französischen Freunde bereits
über 40 deutsche aus Niger Ausfliegen
heute wird es noch weitere Flüge geben
laut Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
sollen die rund 100 in
niederstationierten Bundeswehrsoldaten
im Land bleiben ab nächster Woche will
die Bundeswehr den Flugbetrieb zum
lufttransportstützpunkt in niami wieder
aufnehmen dem Drehkreuz für den Abzug
aus Mali
die westafrikanische Staatengemeinschaft
ECOWAS hat heute noch einmal den Druck
auf die Putschisten erhöht sonst rohe
ein Militäreinsatz
Exzellenzen sie sind hier für die letzte
Möglichkeit für das letzte Mittel die
Vorbereitung einer möglichen
Intervention um die verfassungsgemäße
Ordnung wiederherzustellen
gleichzeitig kündigte Eco was an sei
eine Delegation in Niger und mit den
Putschisten zu verhandeln für morgen
haben Putsch Unterstützer in Nigers
Hauptstadt niami zu neuen
Demonstrationen aufgerufen der Kampf um
die Macht im Land geht weiter
Bela russische Kampfhubschrauber sind
durch polnischen Luftraum geflogen
Polens Verteidigungsministerium stuft
dies als gezielte Provokation ein und
informierte die NATO zudem wird Polen
weitere Truppen an die Grenze zu Belarus
schicken
warschau ist vor allem auch besorgt weil
sich im Belarus Kämpfer der russischen
privat Armee Wagner aufhalten sollen
über den Vorfall und die Folgen Berichte
lindern
es sind diese Aufnahmen die in Polen
Besorgnis auslösen eine Frauen
polnischen Bier wo wir sehr fotografiert
Helikopter aus Belarus die Hubschrauber
fliegen zu tief können vom Radarsystem
nicht erfasst werden
sie flogen aus dieser Richtung und sie
drehten hier zurück ich wohne hier und
ich dachte sie werden meine Scheune
treffen
die Regierung bestätigt was Belarus
bestreitet die Verletzung polnischen
Luftraums die Aktionen des Lukaschenko
Regimes haben einen provokativen
Charakter solche Aktionen der Truppen
des minsker-regimes werden von uns nicht
toleriert
schon einmal hat Polen in diesem Sommer
Truppen an der Grenze verstärkt als
Reaktion auf die Nachricht dass sich die
berüchtigte wagnergruppe in Belarus
befindet es soll gemeinsame Übungen mit
dem Militär geben Wagner in der direkten
Nachbarschaft für Polen eine Gefahr
nicht nur wegen der Gruppe selbst die
Behörden befürchten auch Wagner könnte
helfen Migranten über die Grenze nach
Polen zu bringen dort steht zwar ein
Zaun seit 2021 tausende Migranten über
Belarus in die EU kamen doch er ist
nicht unüberwindbar seit Monaten steigen
die Zahlen wieder
diese Migranten werden eindeutig gelenkt
das Überqueren der Barriere wäre ohne
die Bilder russischen Kräfte kaum
möglich die geben den Menschen Werkzeuge
damit sie Gänge oder Leitern bauen
können
der Grenzschutz spricht von hybrider
Kriegsführung die Regierung von einer
gezielten Provokation die Lagern der
Ostgrenze Polens ist angespannt
eine weitere Anklage gegen Ex-Präsident
Donald Trump es ist die dritte innerhalb
weniger Monate und diese Anklage vor
einem Bundesgericht wiegt am schwersten
denn es geht um die
US-Präsidentschaftswahl 2020 und die
darauf folgender Stürmung des Kapitols
durch Anhänger und Anhängerinnen von
Trump Trump wird unter anderem
Verschwörung vorgeworfen er soll
versucht haben die Wahl zu beeinflussen
jetzt hat er Geschworenen Gericht die
Anklage zugelassen die Einzelheiten von
MRT wissen
Jax Smith hat grünes Licht von den
Geschworenen der Sonderermittler soll
Donald Trump zur Rechenschaft ziehen
denn der so steht es in der Anklage
Schrift habe eine Verschwörung angeführt
um die Vereinigten Staaten zu betrügen
Wähler zu entmündigen und einen
offizielles Verfahren zu behindern
am 6 Januar 2021 war nie gekannter
Angriff auf den Sitz der amerikanischen
Demokratie er war gefeuert durch Lügen
Lügen des Angeklagten mit der Absicht
einer Kernaufgabe des us-systems zu
Schaden
beim Sturm aufs Kapitol hatten Trump
Anhänger versucht die offizielle
Bestätigung der Wahl Joe bidens zum
Präsidenten zu stoppen aufgestachelt von
Donald Trump persönlich
wir ziehen zum Kapitol mit Schwäche
können wir unser Land nicht
zurückerobern ihr müsst Stärke zeigen
stark sein
Trump nennt die neue Anklage einen
illegalen Eingriff in den Wahlkampf
bittet um Spenden und lässt sein
Wahlkampf Team das Verfahren mit
Methoden des Nazi-Regimes vergleichen
bei dieser Anklage geht es um nichts
weniger als um einen Umsturzversuch eine
Verurteilung Trumps würde die
autoritären Gelüste im republikanischen
lagerbremsen das Präsidentenamt über
jede Kontrolle zu erheben ein Freispruch
weil sich die Geschworenen nicht einig
sind würde die Chance des abgewählten
Ex-Präsidenten auf einen Comeback
befeuert am späten Donnerstag will Trump
vor der Richterin in Washington wie
schon in den anderen Fällen auf nicht
schuldig plädieren
Deutschland steckt in einer
Wirtschaftsflaute das Wachstum statt
niert und der IWF sagt für das
Gesamtjahr sogar einen leichten Rückgang
der Wirtschaftsleistung voraus
mehrere Unternehmer verwendet zeigen
sich alarmiert und rufen nach dem Staat
sie fordern Steuerentlastungen und
billigen Industriestrom das von
Finanzminister Lindner geplante
Wachstumschancen Gesetz reicht ihnen
Buchwald berichtet
Robert Habeck auf Sommertour der
Minister letzte Woche in Duisburg
gestern in Hamburg heute nun fordert
Habeck mehr Entlastungen für die
Wirtschaft vor allem ein
subventionierten industriestrompreis der
liberale Koalitionspartner bleibt jedoch
skeptisch deswegen wäre es schön wenn er
havix sich darauf konzentriert den
Strompreis grundsätzlich zu senken wir
können nicht immer auf der einen Seite
die Rahmenbedingungen in Deutschland
verteuern denn auf der anderen Seite mit
staatlichen Subventionen versuchen
Preise zu reduzieren dass der falsche
Ansatz Finanzminister Linden hat deshalb
ein wachstumschancengesetz vorgeschlagen
Ziel Steuerentlastungen weniger
Bürokratie ein erster Schritt sagt die
Wirtschaft weitere aber müssten folgen
wir haben hohe Steuern im
internationalen Vergleich sehr hohe
Energiepreise im internationalen
Vergleich das schränkt die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ein und auch die
Investitionen hierzulande deswegen ist
es wichtig Anreize zu schaffen dass die
Unternehmen hier bleiben der Opposition
reicht das jedoch nicht Angesicht
schlechter Wirtschaftsdaten müsste sich
nun der Kanzler selbst momentlastungen
kümmern wir brauchen dringend einen
Krisengipfel mit der deutschen
Wirtschaft denn täglich kommen neue hier
das Botschaften und das ist wirklich für
unseren Sozialstaat sehr dramatisch auch
und für die Arbeitsplätze und für die
Industrie hier und den Mittelstand
Mittelstand traditionell der
Wachstumsmotor der deutschen Wirtschaft
gerade aus diesem Unternehmen aber
kommen immer mehr Alarmsignale auch
wegen hoher Energiepreise aber bei
weitem nicht alleine
seit heute leben wir global gesehen auf
Pump denn der zweite August ist
weltweiter erdüberlastungstag wer eine
us-umweltorganisation berechnet hat das
heißt die für dieses Jahr verfügbaren
Ressourcen der Erde sind bereits
aufgebraucht um weiter so wirtschaften
zu können bräuchte die Menschheit 1,7
Erden statt nur einer Inga Rabe und Mako
Sommerferien in ganz Deutschland
Schlange stehen für den wohlverdienten
Urlaub auch wenn bei manchen das
schlechte Gewissen im Gepäck ist klar
jetzt jede Woche in Urlaub zu fliegen
ist natürlich auch nicht gut aber einmal
im Jahr ist das glaube ich kein Problem
ist keine andere Möglichkeit vor 1980
bis 2019 vor Corona hat sich die Zahl
der Flug Passagiere fast für siebenfach
ein Zuwachs der zeigt wie schwer sich
die Welt oft damit tut nachhaltiger zu
werden
fliegen muss teurer werden durch ein
CO2-Preis rückerstattet über ein
klimabergergeld dann wird weniger
geflogen
zugleich brauchen wir aber auch
Alternativen das heißt wir müssen den
Bahnverkehr ausbauen wir brauchen
nachtzugverbindung wir brauchen
attraktive Strecken damit die Leute
statt mit dem Flugzeug mit der Bahn
fahren können ein anderes Beispiel die
Seefracht weil weltweit Konsum und
Handel wachsen hat sich die Zahl der
umgeschlagenen Container allein seit
2000 mehr als verdreifacht die Schiffe
schnell auf klimafreundlich umzustellen
ist unmöglich beim globalen
erdüberlastungstag ist die Richtung auch
deshalb klar seit 1971 wandert er stetig
nach vorne in Richtung Sommer immerhin
das Tempo wird langsamer seit 2005 liegt
der überlastungstag im August gegenüber
dem letzten Jahr gibt es sogar eine
leichte Verbesserung
dieser Trend hat sich zwar tatsächlich
in den vergangenen Jahren abgeflacht
also wir haben keinen starken Anstieg
mehr darüber Nutzung aber die dringend
nötige Trendumkehr die wir so schnell
wie möglich bräuchten die ist leider
bisher nicht zu sehen vor allem der
Treibhausgasausstoß müsste sinken im
Flugverkehr eine Herausforderung die
Passagierzahlen sind in vielen Ländern
schon fast wieder so hoch wie vor Corona
wenn Kinder vernachlässigt werden oder
Gewalt erfahren spricht man von
Kindeswohlgefährdung ihre Zahl ist 2022
auf ein Höchstwert gestiegen so dass
Statistische Bundesamt
demnach waren mehr als 62.000 Kinder und
Jugendliche betroffen vier Prozent mehr
als ein Jahr zuvor die meisten Fälle
betrafen Hinweise auf Vernachlässigung
sowie körperliche und psychische Gewalt
in der Gedenkstätte Auschwitz berkenau
ist dann die Ermordung von rund 500.000
sind die und Roma durch die
Nationalsozialisten erinnert worden in
vielen osteuropäischen Ländern lebten
Roma immer noch unter
apartheidähnlichen Bedingungen sagte der
Vorsitzende des Zentralrates der Sinti
und Roma in Deutschland Romani Rose
im damaligen deutschen
Konzentrationslager ermordete die ISS
allein vom zweiten auf den dritten
august 1944 mehr als 4000 Kinder Frauen
und Männer in den Gaskammern
Papst franziskus ist zu einem
fünftägigen Besuch in Portugal
eingetroffen es ist seine erste
Auslandsreise seit einem längeren
Klinikaufenthalt im Juni Tag Eins stand
ganz im Zeichen der Politik in einer
Grundsatzrede forderte der Pontifex neue
politische Zukunftsvisionen von Europa
die Welt braucht Europa als Brückenbauer
und Friedensstifter sagte er
Anlass der Reise ist der katholische
Weltjugendtag
mehr als eine halbe Million Menschen aus
aller Welt werden dafür in Lissabon
erwartet Anna Warsberg hat einige beim
Weltjugendtag getroffen
wir begleiten fünf von hunderttausenden
Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen die
hier nach Lissabon gekommen sind um
gemeinsam katholische Weltkirche zu
erleben Pia Stamer aus Hamburg war als
Teenager in raus aus der Kirche wie sie
sagt und heute sehr engagiert in einem
Kloster trotz und mit den ganzen
Problemen der Kirche weil das Problem
ergibt und wenn man die offen noch
einstehen muss aber gleichzeitig hat die
katholische Kirchen wird mir bisher so
viel gegeben Anhalt an meinem Glauben an
Freude und Spaß
deswegen ich sie jetzt nicht unbedingt
also jetzt sage ich verlasse und gehen
nie wieder hin viel mehr gehe ist darum
den individuellen Glauben zu leben und
sich hier beim Weltjugendtag abseits vom
offiziellen Programm mit anderen
auszutauschen dafür wollen wir und die
anderen erstmal zum Goethe-Institut von
Lissabon Treffpunkt der deutschen Gruppe
Benjamin Lipinski setzt sich für
Veränderung in der katholischen Kirche
ein vor allem das queere Menschen
akzeptiert werden
ich will nicht dass der Laden nur von
den regiert wird
ja die der konservative Einstellung
mitbringen und die diskriminieren ganz
eindeutig viele von denen die wir hier
kennengelernt haben erzählen dass sie
als Kinder in ihrem Gemeinden
Machtmissbrauch durch geistliche erlebt
haben der Papst will bei seinem
weltjugendtagsbesuch auch
Opfer sexuellen Missbrauchs durch
portugiesische Kleriker treffen bei den
vielen Messen und Konzerten soll diese
Woche in Lissabon aber vor allem der
gemeinsame glauben im Vordergrund stehen
und gefeiert werden
in Wacken machten Regen und Schlamm am
Morgen tausenden Heavy Metal Fans ein
Strich durch die Rechnung einlassstopp
aus Sicherheitsgründen das Festival
konnte dann zwar starten aber nur mit
rund 50.000 statt 85.000 Fans
statt Wiese vor den Bühnen teilweise 20
cm lang und es regnet weiter die
Stimmung scheint es nicht zu schaden
zumindest ein bisschen Matsch gehört zu
warten ja auch irgendwie dazu
und seine Nachrichtensendung gehört auch
Sport und darauf schauen wir jetzt
morgen mittags in Deutschland
Fußballerinnen ja wieder richtig
gefordert Rudi genau und zwar im letzten
Gruppenspiel und vom Gruppensieg bis zum
Ausscheiden ist bei der WM in Australien
und Neuseeland alles möglich nur mit
einem Sieg gegen Südkorea kommt das Team
von bundestrainerinnen Martina Forst
Tecklenburg sicher weiter
bloß nicht ins Stolpern kommen lautet
das Motto der DFB-Frauen für das dritte
und entscheidende gruppenmatch droht bei
einer Pleite das früheste WM aus
klar weiß man dass es vielleicht auch
das letzte sein könnte aber dann wollen
wir uns gar nicht beschäftigen sondern
wollen morgen daraus gehen zeigen was
wir können unsere Qualität auf dem Platz
bringen um sein Team zu schlagen der
Engländer Collin Bell wurde einst mit
den Frankfurterinnen Champions League
Sieger vermittelt seit 2019 den
südkoreanerinnen seinen Spielidee
fressen sehr selten aber vielleicht
überraschen Sie uns ja morgen also Colin
Bell ist ja ein Trainer Fuchs und doch
geht das Team von Forst Tecklenburg als
klarer Favorit in die Begegnung auch
weil mit Marina Hegering nach
überstandener Fersenverletzung erstmals
die Abwehrchefin auflaufen wird genau
rechtzeitig um die Hürde fürs
Achtelfinale zu nehmen
also dann Deutschland Südkorea morgen in
Sportstudio live bei uns von 11:15 Uhr
an und ein Debakel erlebten die mit
Favoritinnen aus Brasilien die Esau kam
gegen Jamaika nicht über einen 0:0
hinaus und muss nach der Vorrunde
abreisen eine ganz große Fußballerin
geht ungekrönt
mit der Auswechslung in der 81 Minute
endet die Nationalmannschaftskarriere
der sechsmaligen Weltfußballerin Marta
es ist ein schwerer Moment für mich um
zu sprechen es war nicht die WM von der
ich geträumt habe nicht einmal in meinen
schlimmsten Albträumen
Brasilien kann zu keinem Zeitpunkt dem
Spiel seinen Stempel aufdrücken Jamaika
ein ebenbürtiger Gegner Martha darf auf
der Bank noch einmal hoffen dass es doch
nicht ihr letzter WM-Auftritt gewesen
sein könnte Brasilien in der
Nachspielzeit fast noch mit dem
Siegtreffer doch es bleibt beim 0:0
Jamaika schafft die Sensation und steht
im Achtelfinale
wir sind ein tolles Team niemand hat uns
das zugetraut aber wir haben immer an
uns geklaut
die Karriere von Martha endet ohne
WM-Titel aber der Respekt der
Gegnerinnen bleibt für immer
Frankreich gewann ihn Parallelspiel mit
sechs zu drei gegen Panama und sicherte
sich den Gruppensieg damit zieht das
Team mit Jamaika in die k.o Runde ein
das wären dann auch die möglichen
Gegnerinnen für Deutschland in
Achtelfinale
zum Abschluss seiner Asien Reise gewann
Bayern München in Singapur mit 4:3 gegen
den FC Liverpool mit Teenager die
Manager Jürgen Klopp den Siegtreffer
erzielte der erst 20-jährige Franz
Krätzig
die 39 Jahre alte Tanja Scholz hat bei
der para Schwimm-WM in Manchester
innerhalb von 25 Minuten zweimal Gold
gewonnen nach dem Titel über 100 Meter
Freistil siegt die in komplett
Querschnittgelähmte Athletin auch über
150 Meter Lagen Gold Nummer drei für
Deutschland holt sich Paralympics Sieger
taliso Engel über 100 Meter Brust und
verpasst dabei seine weltrekordmarke nur
um 2900 Sekunden
trotzdem gratulation großartig
und zum Schluss noch ein himmlisches
Spektakel für alle die gestern uns graue
guckten ein supermond am Nachthimmel zum
Greifen nahe Schiener in Jerusalem und
mysteriös im Wolken verhangenen Himmel
von Sarajevo in Athen versammelten sich
Fans am Poseidon Tempel gerade ist der
Mond der Erde besonders nahe was ihn
größer und heller erscheinen lässt wie
auch hier in Dresden bei diesen
supermond verpasst hat bekommt noch eine
Chance und zwar am 31 August
welche Lottozahlen gezogen wurden
erfahren Sie jetzt die Gewinnzahlen 7 21
23 29 30 44 Superzahl ist die vier
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
stürmisch und gewitterig wird die Nacht
im Nordwesten morgen aber zeigt sich
auch mal wieder die Sonne etwas länger
wo genau das erfahren Sie gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute journal können
Sie an diesem Abend um 22 Uhr sehen mit
einer gallinek tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend sehr schön zu erkennen ist
hier die Wolken Spirale von dem
Sturmtief Xan dieses Sturmtief brachte
uns heute erstmal viel Regen und dann in
der zweiten Tageshälfte auch kräftige
Gewitter das sehen Sie an den kleinen
gelben blitzen die zogen vor allen
Dingen über Nordrhein-Westfalen und
Niedersachsen und diese Gewitter breiten
sich im Laufe der Nacht weiter nach
Nordosten aus es kann dazu auch
stürmischen Wind geben die Temperaturen
in dieser Nacht sinken auf Werte
zwischen 17 und 12 Grad und morgen
liegen dann die Höchsttemperaturen in
den westlichen Mittelgebirgen um 17 Grad
im Osten wird es mit 24 Grad wärmer und
auch morgen wird dieses Tief uns noch
weiter beschäftigen morgen früh liegt
dieses Sturmtief Xanten hier an der
Nordseeküste und bringt noch viel Wind
mit es gibt schwere Sturmböen oder sogar
orkanartige Sturmböen hier im Harz auf
dem Brocken und auch Sturmböen im
Schwarzwald
wird morgen garstiges Wetter in
Norddeutschland geben viel Regen immer
wieder mit Gewittern durchsetzt deutlich
freundlicher ist es dagegen im südlichen
Brandenburg und in Sachsen sowie vom
Vogtland bis zum Bodensee und sehr
wechselhaft geht es dann in den nächsten
Tagen weiter bei 14 bis 24 Grad guten
Abend